- Il arrive à titre de premier
ministre, et ressort en tant que
chef du parti libéral.
Incontournable visite pour
mettre un terme à la rumeur,
le pays est officiellement
en campagne électorale.
- Les Canadiens iront donc
aux urnes le 20 septembre.
- Justin Trudeau se défend de
profiter de sondages favorables
pour obtenir une majorité.
"Même en pleine pandémie, même
devant la menace d'une quatrième
vague, les choix que lui ont
imposés la crise sanitaire dit-
il, doivent pouvoir être
approuvé par les Canadiens".
JUSTIN TRUDEAU
chef, Parti libéral du Canada
- Les Canadiens méritent de
pouvoir se faire entendre,
de pouvoir exprimer leur voix et
leur choix sur comment on va en
finir avec cette pandémie.
- L'opposition conservatrice,
qui dénonçait hier encore
la nécessité d'une élection,
n'a pas mis de temps à joindre
les hostilités.
- Il faut toujours avoir
un plan.
- Erin O'Toole promet une
approche fraîche sur la gestion
de la pandémie émise sur la
création d'un million d'emplois
et l'équilibre budgétaire d'ici
10 ans pour se démarquer.
ERIN O'TOOLE, chef, Parti
conservateur du Canada
- Il y a cinq parties, mais deux
choix. Les conservateurs d'un
côté, ou plus de scandale,
plus de dépenses et plus de
dette de l'autre.
YVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET
chef, Bloc québécois
- Les Québécoises et
les Québécois ont laissé
comprendre assez clairement
qu'ils ne veulent pas
d'une majorité libérale.
- Le chef du Bloc québécois,
lui, ne comprend pas pourquoi
soudainement le Parlement est
soudainement devenu
disfonctionnel aux yeux
de Justin Trudeau. Il promet de
livrer une chaude lutte au nom
de la défense des intérêts
du Québec.
JAGMEET SINGH, chef, Nouveau
Parti démocratique
- Il y a même un risque pour
les gains que le Québec a faits
pour les deux dernières années
dans le projet de majorité de
Monsieur Trudeau.
- Le NPD qui a régulièrement
offert son appui aux libéraux ne
voit pas non plus pourquoi les
élections sont nécessaires
maintenant, je ne signe se
propose comme le défenseur des
canadiens plus vénérables.
- Avec des néo démocrates vous
avaient quelques de votre bord
qui se batte pour vous.
- Les libéraux font un pari qui
qu'ils bénéficieront de vents
favorables grâce à leur gestion
de la pandémie. Mais ils savent
aussi qu'une quatrième vague
alimentée par une flambée des
nouveaux cas pourrait rapidement
venir assombrir l'horizon
électoral.
Ici Daniel Thibault,
Radio-Canada, Ottawa.